All right. Welcome, everyone. This is the Combating T
Cell Checkpoints Mini Symposium. Thanks for coming.
I'm Megan Berger. I'm an assistant professor at Oregon Health & Science University
in Portland, Oregon, and I'm happy to co-chair this session with Dr.
Justin Klein, who is a professor of medicine at University of Chicago.
So we are both T cell biologists and interested in developing
improved T cell-mediated immunotherapies for cancer.
And so it's great to have the opportunity to organize and
chair this session on just new approaches
to improving T cell function against cancer to try
to further improve patient outcomes.
So we know immune checkpoint inhibitors have made a real impact in
the clinic for many patients. These are things such as anti-PD-1.
However, for many patients, these therapies are not sufficient to
overcome T cell dysfunction in the tumor microenvironment.
And so this session is really focused on some interesting new
approaches to improve T cell function against cancer.
And we're going to cover things from improving T cell
metabolism,
to bolstering cytotoxic function, and also
preventing T cell exhaustion.
So these are really interesting mechanistic talks, and these
mechanisms could be applied, targeting in combination
with checkpoint blockade immunotherapy to bolster endogenous T cell
responses.
The speakers are also looking at these in the context of engineering adoptive T
cell transfer for ACT therapies as well.
So thank you to the speakers for sharing these new insights with us.
And we're actually going to start off with two talks that are focused on improving
T cell metabolism and
trying to develop better immunotherapies for
glioblastoma, which is a notoriously hard to treat cancer in the brain.
So with that, I'll just introduce, I don't have names up here,
but Defne.
I should have brought it with me.
Thank you.
Sorry, I'll just introduce Defne Bayik,
who's coming to us from the University of Miami, and she's going to tell us about
DPP4 as a novel checkpoint for CD8 T
cells.
Welcome.
Thank you very much to the session chairs for organizing such an interesting mini
symposium. I am actually a myeloid cell biologist who turned into a T
cell person, not by choice, but that's where the research led
us. So there are no relevant disclosures for this talk.
As the chair highlighted, the first talk is on glioblastoma, or in short
GBM, which is the most common primary malignant brain tumor.
So to underscore the
importance of developing new treatments for this disease, the standard of
care has not changed in the last two decades, but unfortunately, immune
therapy strategies did not lead to measurable clinical outcomes
thus far. So these tumors are characterized by
immune checkpoint resistance and generally low immune therapy
responses. And we can discuss extensively why that is the
case. The localization of the tumor is an important
factor. It's in the brain. It's hard to get therapeutics there.
But also these tumors are excessively infiltrated by
immune suppressive myeloid cell populations.
Different kind of immune populations are present in this tumor microenvironment.
And these patients are generally characterized by low T cell numbers.
This is induced by both the disease itself and the treatment approaches.
However, there is still somewhat T cell infiltration.
The numbers are low, but they are not undetectable, and those T
cells show the characteristics of exhausted T cells.
So likely a strategy that will generate an
anti-tumor immune response for GBM involves multimodal targeting
that would include the myeloid cells and T cells.
So in an effort to understand the drivers of this myeloid cell recruitment
back in 2022, we reported that there
are some molecules that could inform chemotaxis of these cells to the
microenvironment. So looking at the epigenetic architecture of these
cells, we identified dipeptidyl
peptidase-4, or in short DPP4, as a potential driver
of monastic recruitment to the tumor microenvironment.
But what is this molecule and why it could be important?
So DPP4 is actually understudied, but a very well
drug target.
It's an exopeptidase that is membrane-bound or can be cleaved and released
into plasma, and its best described function is its
exopeptidase activity. It primarily targets
GLP-1, so it has a critical role in insulin glucose metabolism.
However, it is not specific. There are multiple cytokine and chemokine targets,
and their cleavage could affect bioactivity and bioavailability,
but we really don't have a good understanding of how it modulates
cytokines, chemokines.
Also, I mentioned that it's a membrane-bound protein.
It interacts with other proteins that are on the membrane, and therefore it has a
signaling function, which is even
worse described.
But because it is so critical for insulin glucose metabolism, it's very well
drug. So gliptins target DPP4, and there are six
approved inhibitors against these molecules, sitagliptin being the one that is
used most commonly.
So having identified DPP4 as a potential
molecule that is important for immune suppressive myeloid cell activity, we asked
the question: Are the inhibitors effective in patients with
glioblastoma?
So we turned into the Medicare data set and performed a retrospective
analysis where we looked for the patients who were on DPP4
inhibitors. So here the pink line
highlights standard of care.
When we look at the patients who happen to be on gliptins,
DPP4 inhibitors, we observed that they were having much better outcomes
compared to patients who received standard of care.Presumably, these
patients are using this drug because they are diabetic.
So we use metformin as a drug control, and we observed that it didn't
have the same survival benefit that is conferred by inhibition of DPP4.
So the question is that, what is the main target of DPP4?
Yes, it is expressed by myeloids cells, but is it the end of story?
We looked at multiple single cell sequencing data sets and we observed that
CD8 T cells are characterized by profoundly high levels of
DPP4 expression. And we can recapitulate this on
our orthotopic GPR models, where we observe CD8
T cells were the main expressers of DPP4.
And in fact, they were critical for DPP4 inhibitor response.
So this is a very immune system persistent model.
When we treated these mice with tumors with sitagliptin,
there was a survival benefit, which was totally reversed by inhibition
of CD8 T cells.
So what kind of CD8 T cells express that?
And we did multiple analysis to answer this question.
Initially, we looked at patient samples, and all the cells are exhausted, to
remind you, but we separated based on tox expression, and we observed
that these cells with higher tox expression, presumably these are the terminally
exhausted T cells, had higher levels of DPP4 expression.
We also used an acute and
chronic LC-MS model to study T cell biology more effectively.
Initially, what we observed was naive T cells have high DPP4 expression, but
when they get activated, the expression levels go down, only
to go back up with exhaustion or memory differentiation.
If we again use an orthogonal assay and use a chronic antigen stimulation assay, we
observed that terminally exhausted T cells have much higher levels of
DPP4 expression compared to effector subset.
So this suggests that there is some lineage
activation relationship between DPP4 expression.
But it doesn't necessarily say that the DPP4 is
functional.
To understand better whether it has a functional role, we again pharmacologically
inhibited on T cells and performed an RNA sequencing
experiment. So overall, there were two
clusters of pathway that were upregulated upon inhibition of DPP4
in T cells, one being T cell activation related pathways,
the other being mitochondrial metabolism related pathways.
To functionally confirm that, we can do proliferation assay, and we
observed that both in human and mouse, the inhibition of
DPP4 increases proliferation rates.
We observed that these T cells,
that are treated with sitagliptin are generating more cytotoxic mediators.
We also observed that they were better at killing cancer targets in an
antigen-specific manner.
What about the metabolism? So we have a growing appreciation for dynamic regulation
of T cell metabolism and how it relates to function.
At the basal state, they have lower metabolic activity, but when T cells get
activated, they first increase glycolysis rate, which is accompanied by
proliferation. And at the effector stage, they do use oxidative
phosphorylation for killing function.
And when they differentiate into memory cells or get exhausted, their metabolism
again goes through another round of change.
So
based on this, we did a targeted metabolomic analysis and what
we observed was there was a significant upregulation of metabolites that are
associated with nucleotide and amino acid metabolisms, which matches
our observation that these cells are proliferating.
We also observed that both TCA cycle-related metabolites and
glycolysis-related metabolites were getting upregulated.
So is that really the case? We can look at that by
measuring oxidative phosphorylation rate and glycolysis and looking
at oxidative phosphorylation. We observed an
increase in spare mitochondrial respiratory capacity, and we
also observed increased glycolysis rates, suggesting that T cells were becoming
more metabolically fit when we inhibit the DPP4.
What about the mechanism? I mentioned to you that DPP4 is mostly described as
an exo peptidase, but it does have a signaling function.
So what could these signaling partners could be?
To address that, we did a phosphoproteomics analysis, and we observed
upregulation in T cell receptor signaling mediators.
But our top target, unexpectedly, was an enzyme called
glutamate carboxylase 1, or GAD1 in short.
So GAD1 is an important metabolic enzyme that converts
glutamate into GABA and then feeds it into TCA cycle.
So it matches our observation that TCA cycle is getting upregulated.
So does this enzyme really play a role in T cell
functionality and DPP4 inhibitor response?
Lucky for us, this is an enzyme that is inhibited in the context
of neuroscience. So there is an inhibitor called L-glycine that we can
test its functional role.
So in both mouse
and human T cells, what we observed was that inhibition of DPP4 with
sitagliptin led to an increase in spare respiratory capacity,
which was mitigated by inhibition of GAD1.
Also, we observed that the proliferative advantage conferred by
DPP4 inhibition was blocked when we
inhibited GAD1.
So this really identifies GAD1 as a downstream modulator of T cell
biology.
But more important, what is the functional importance of this observation?
Can we repurpose this clinically used DPP4 inhibitors
for treatment, and can we combine with immune therapies?
So one thing that is important was for us to
identify whether
CAR T cells have the same kind of response.
And here I'm showing you mouse B7-H3 CAR T cells, but
we do have similar results with human IL-13 receptor alpha 2 and CD19
CAR T cells.So in this experiment, what we did was a chronic
stimulation, repeated stimulation experiment.
So vehicle-treated CAR T cells, beyond stimulation three, lose their
efficacy, and they no longer lyse tumor targets effectively.
But what we observed with the dapagliflozin-treated CAR Ts were that they retained
their functional activity to up to eight stimulation.
And in fact, when we treat these CAR Ts during the manufacturing
process and then transfer them into
mouse models with pediatric gliomas, we observed we achieved a better
tumor control, suggesting that these CAR T cells were more therapeutically active.
So all in all, what I shared with you today suggests that DPP4 could
serve as a immunometabolic checkpoint where the expression level is informed
by T cell activation state. And when we repurpose a Type 2
diabetes drug, we can reinvigorate T cell
metabolism and increase functional activity for anti-tumor
function.
So with that, I would like to thank Dr.
Oriana Taran-Pumar, who is the postdoc who led this project, along with all
the collaborators, and happy to answer any questions you have. Thank you.
Just come up to the microphone if you have questions.
So I'll start with one.
So your studies all used the inhibitor of
DPP4, yeah? I'm just curious how specific of an inhibitor
that is and whether you looked at genetic or conditional targeting of
DPP4.
We did use global knockout mice, DPP4.
We didn't use conditional, but global knockout mice have the same effect.
We also treated T cells that are obtained from DPP4 knockout mice and
treated them with the drug to confirm specificity, and we
believe that the effect is specific for the most part.
I know that there is potential of target effect on DPP7,
DPP8, other
DPP family molecules. But in knockout mice, we
see that the response is
diminishing, the drug response.
Thank you.
Pretty specific.
Great talk. Thank you.
Two questions.
What about the effect on the myeloid component of these tumors?
Yes. So it does affect
chemotaxis, but it doesn't seem to affect functionality.
So it looks like they have different biological outcomes on different cell
types specific, and that's one of the reasons why we went into CAR T
cells as well.
Mm-hmm. Okay. And
is the data that you showed,
has that been validated or shown to be present in human
GBM tumors, tumors taken out of patients?
Was that all mouse data, or was that from human tumors?
So both the single-cell sequencing and-
Yeah
... patient flow cytometer-based assays, we do see T cells express
DPP4.
Is there any interest in a window of opportunity study to try to
use
some dosing strategies to see if you can validate this in-
Definitely.
... patients going forward.
We would be much interested in collaborating with you on that.
Yeah. That'd be really great.
So currently, I haven't shared with the group yet, but we have some data on lung
cancer as well, and thus the IIT that we are in the
process ramping up right now, but
definitely.
That would be great. Thank you.
That was great, thank you. I have a question.
On one of your earlier slides, you mentioned that you have both GBM and adjacent
tissues, and it seemed like you grouped those together.
Right.
Was that murine data?
Mouse.
Oh.
No, human. I'm sorry. Human.
That was human data. Okay. Did you analyze the tumor and the adjacent tissues
separately?
We did. So one of the reasons we did that is, as I mentioned earlier in the talk,
there are very few T cells, right?
Okay.
So I had to achieve a good
number of T cells. That was something we had to do.
Would you be able to speak to whether you think these
changes are reflected in the adjacent tissue to the same extent, or were
there differences? Were you able to look at the two compartments separately at all?
I don't think our data is powered enough to do that.
Okay.
But from what we see, there is not really that much of a
difference. T cell state is the one that informs more than the
localization of the T cell.
Oh, okay. And sorry, just one final question.
How far was this adjacent tissue?
I need to ask our neurosurgeon collaborator-
Okay
... on that specific.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Okay. Thank you very much.
All right.
Next, we want to welcome Keisuke Watanabe from the National Cancer
Center in Japan, presenting his work, "On-Demand GLUT3
Expression Augments CAR T Cell Metabolic Fitness and
Antitumor Efficacy While Preventing Toxicity in
Glioblastoma Models." It's a mouthful. All right, please.
Thank you for the kind introduction, and thank you for giving me this great
opportunity to present our data here.
So
this is my disclosure.
So chimeric antigen receptor T cell therapy has shown significant
efficacy in hematologic malignancies, and currently,
several types of CAR T cell products are available in clinic.
However, their application is limited to B-cell-derived
hematological malignancies
by targeting CD19 or BCMA. So our goal was
to drive this attractive platform for
solid tumors. So in this specific
project, we wanted to aim glioblastoma by CAR T cells.
As you know, glioblastoma is a very dismal disease.
It has very poor prognosis, and also, it is
immunologically cold tumorSo immunotherapies including immune
checkpoint blockade is not so effective.
And also, glioblastoma has some idea of
tumor-associated antigens like EGFRvIII.
So should be ideal targets for targeted therapy,
including CAR T cell therapy. So this is just
example of CAR T cell therapy against
glioblastoma targeting EGFR and
cytokine receptor alpha from University of Pennsylvania.
So as you can see, the result is very,
very
encouraging. So there are some response, and there are CAR T cell
expansion in cerebrospinal fluid, and also a patient
survived a long time.
But still many patients experience relapse or refractory
disease just after CAR T cell treatment, so CAR T cell
persistence does matter.
So among many challenges
that can limit CAR T cell persistence or
CAR T cell efficacy. So in this project,
we focused on metabolic barrier in tumor
microenvironment in solid tumors.
So as you know, cancer cells are consuming a lot of glucose and
excreting lactate by aerobic
glycolysis, so-called Warburg effect.
So along with vascular problem or other many factors,
the tumor microenvironment is very low glucose condition.
And also
brain tumor is very special. So brain is highly dependent on
glucose on their energy resource.
And also they express a high level of
glucose transporter and uptaking a lot of glucose.
So in such low glucose condition, so CAR T cells cannot
uptake enough glucose, and also it can induce T
cell dysfunction.
So first, we determined a glucose level of
glioblastoma using a patient-derived
surgical specimen. So as you can see, glucose level of
glioblastoma is very low, less than zero point five
millimolar. And the glucose level was much lower than
other cancer types, for example, lung cancer or
colon cancers. And this low glucose condition
completely suppressed cytolytic activity of CAR T
cells in vitro experiment. And also, CAR T
cells almost completely lost capacity of cytokine
production in such low glucose condition.
And in addition, so a bunch of positive regulator
of T cell effector function was down-modulated
in gene expression profile. So there definitely
exist metabolic checkpoint in glioblastoma for
CAR T cell therapy.
But very interestingly, glioblastoma cells themselves are
surviving and also rather expanding in such low glucose
condition by expressing high-affinity glucose transporter
GLUT3. So GLUT3 has a fivefold
higher affinity to glucose than GLUT1 that is ubiquitously
expressed in normal cells, including T cells.
So our strategy is to arm CAR
T cells with this high-affinity GLUT3,
so that to make CAR T cell competitive
in glucose uptaking this low glucose
condition.
So first, we tested very simple strategy.
So we just connected GLUT3 and EGFRvIII CAR
via T2A sequence. This enabled a
simultaneous and also a continuous
expression of GLUT3 on the membrane of CAR.
We confirmed increased GLUT3 expression and increased glucose
uptake in GLUT3-expressing CAR T cells.
And this is analysis of
glycolytic metabolism. So as you can see,
it's reasonable. Conventional CAR T cells couldn't maintain nice glucose
metabolism. On the other hand,
GLUT3 expression
energized, forced this OCR. So
both OXPHOS and glycolysis are like this.
And also it increased cytokine production, also
enhanced cytotoxicity like this.
So we are happy to see these results.
We decided to
move to mouse experiment. So in this model, so
intracranial inoculated U87 Delta
glioblastoma tumor cells were treated with
intravenous injections of CAR T cells.
And we also did tumor challenge to ask
persistence of CAR T cells.
But result was disappointing. So as you can see, we couldn't see
any additional benefit of GLUT3 expression to
conventional CAR T cells. So Kaplan-Meier
almost overlapped. So one reason was
toxicity. We observed some severe body weight loss in
CAR T cells expressing GLUT3. But we
found another distinct disadvantage of GLUT3
expression on T cells. As you can see,
GLUT3-expressing CAR T cells
hyperactivated status.
In addition, it drove high
drove T cell differentiation.
So this is CAR T cell analysis from mouse experiment.
So as you can see, GLUT3-expressing CAR T cell lost CC
chemo expression and also indicated
this kind of terminal differentiated T cells.
And also-PD-1 expression and PD-1/TIM-3 expression was
very high in GLUT3-expressing CAR T cells.
So we hypothesized, so overactivation of CAR T cells by
continuous and excess glucose uptake via GLUT3
might abrogate persistence of CAR T cell.
So to solve this problem, so we design
on-demand expression of GLUT3 like this.
So in this system, GLUT3 is off when CAR
T cell is steady state.
And then GLUT3 is turned on
once CAR T cells recognize tumor antigen and
activate it in tumor microenvironment.
So this enables the on-demand glucose uptake
depending on
glucose demand of T cells. So as
you can see, there is no GLUT3 expression in
unstimulated T cells and nice GLUT3
expression in stimulated T cells.
So this is the expression profile of conventional CAR T cells and stable
and on-demand GLUT3-expressing T cells.
As you can see, both a stable and on-demand GLUT3
expression nicely activated T cells.
But at the same time, a stable GLUT3 expression
induced apoptosis, but on-demand one didn't.
So we confirmed this in flow cytometry, so you can see higher annexin
5 positive cells in stable GLUT3-expressing CAR T cells.
So it affected T cell proliferation.
So we assumed this was attributed to hyperactivation of
CAR T cells via
over uptake of glucose. And also,
on-demand GLUT3 expression in CAR T cells maintained a naive cell
phenotype, and also,
on-demand GLUT3 expression in CAR T cells suppressed
PD-1/TIM-3 expression.
So again, we tested this function in a low glucose
condition like this. So we confirmed increased
glucose uptake and also increased glycolysis like this.
And also,
same, so conventional CAR T cell couldn't produce
cytokine in this low glucose condition, but on-demand GLUT3
expression recovered cytokine production.
And on-demand GLUT3 expression enhanced Cytoc
C like this. So again, we tested this in mouse model,
so using same model with tumor re-challenge.
So we used two cell lines separately.
So again, stable GLUT3 expression couldn't
add
any survival benefit, and two
lines overlap like this. So only on-demand
GLUT3-expressing CAR T cells achieved
survival benefit like this green line.
So this is tumor burden by BLI. So as you can see, conventional
CAR T cells or a CAR T cell stably
expressing GLUT3 failed to suppress tumor in
some mice, but all mice achieved
CR in
on-demand GLUT3-expressing CAR T cells.
And also importantly, in stable GLUT3-expressing CAR T
cells, mice experienced a severe body weight loss with
a high serum TNF-alpha. So which means
this very hyperactivated and short active and toxic
feature of stable GLUT3-expressing CAR T cells.
But on-demand one didn't show that kind of toxicity.
So lastly, so we did safety assessment of GLUT3-expressing
CAR T cells, focusing on CNS damage, so
like ICANS in human setting. So this is a histological
analysis using neural cell damage
specific marker, Fluoro-JIC. So you can see some
damaged cells in control brain treated with
insulin that
induce hypoglycemia. You see these
damaged cells. But there is no damaged cells in brain
treated with on-demand GLUT3-expressing CAR T cells.
And this is just quantification. You can see some damage in brain treated
with stable GLUT3-expressing CAR T cell, but not in
on-demand
GLUT3-expressing CAR T cells. And also, we did cognitive
and behavior test. This is a kind of test for ICANS.
So in this experiment, so we didn't see any
change of cognitive behavior
alternation in on-demand GLUT3 system like this.
So this should be safe for clinical application. So this is just summary.
So we developed a on-demand GLUT3 expression system to
metabolically empower CAR T cells depending on their glucose demand,
so which induced durable anti-tumor efficacy while
preventing toxicity in grapefruit storm model.
So we propose that on-demand, but not stable metabolic fitness
is a novel concept to maximize the anti-tumor efficacy
of CAR T cell and against solid tumors.
So I'd like to thank all members involved in this study, and this is our funding
source. Thank you for your attention, and happy to take any
question.
Very interesting talk. We have a couple
minutes for questions.
Hi. Zach Gill from Penn. Hi. This is really nice work.
I've got a couple of questions for you, but maybe can you speculate on why it
is that
stably expressed GLUT3 caused um-
differentiation of the T cells. What are the mechanisms or the
signaling pathways that were activated in T cells that overexpress
GLUT3?
That seemed surprising to me.
Okay. Thank you so much. Actually, so I didn't
analyze pathway precisely, but when I stimulate
T cells with GLUT3, it activate
too much with
some
marker with a PD1 or something. So it probably, it drove very
hyper activation. It also make
differentiation. But I didn't check some
precise downstream pathway.
Do you think, just to follow up and maybe speculate,
you would expect that there would be increased intracellular
glucose concentrations?
Yeah.
Is that something that one can measure and look at the metabolic pathways
that are-
Yeah, I think so. So when I check the glucose concentrations, the intracellular
glucose concentration is very high when I equip a
stable GLUT3 expression in T cells.
Thank you.
Sure.
Yeah. Hi. Thank you. Very interesting talk.
My question was somewhere in the same
area, because I would think that just because
a substrate is available inside the cell doesn't mean the cell will
necessarily metabolize it. It can accumulate, generating glycogen,
for example.
So
just because you express a transporter on the cell surface and
it brings glucose into the cell, doesn't mean that the cell will necessarily
utilize it. So have you explored the
different metabolic pathways that these cells have
when you express GLUT3? For example,
oxidative phosphorylation or
glutaminolysis or something like that?
Because I would probably
think that it wouldn't dictate how the cell
behaves.
Thank you for your question. So probably so the question is
if I
analyze other than glucose pathway or
something.
Sorry, again?
Sorry. So your question is if I under... Yeah.
It was in the same area of the last question,
whether you had explored the specific metabolisms
of the cells when you overexpress
GLUT3. Which kind of metabolism
does this cell have? Like glycolytic or
other type? Because it would be counterintuitive for me to believe
that just because you express GLUT3, it would necessarily dictate the
metabolism of the T cell. Just like, what do you think?
What do you
believe is happening?
Yeah. Actually, so
I'm not sure this is accurate answer, but it was surprising for me
because, so
only I equipped
glucose transporter, but also fatty acid oxidation changed,
and also glycolysis OXPHOS
balance was changed. So it was surprising.
Yeah, but that's I
answer the question. So I
didn't analyze a very precise pathway, so I
cannot say the reason why it happened.
But anyway, so
what I modified was glucose pathway, but it changed some fatty acid
oxidation or other pathways, so it was surprising for us.
Okay. Thank you so much.
All right. Thanks a lot for the great talk.
Thanks so much.
All right. Next up is Adam Blaisdell from the University
of California, San Francisco, who's going to tell us about, I'm just going to
shorten it, the role of A20 in enforcing a critical block in exhausted
CD8 T cell degranulation.
Perfect. Yeah, I should have done that last time.
All right. So good afternoon. I'm Adam Blaisdell, physician scientist at UCSF.
Today I'll talk about the under-recognized problem of perforin
degranulation in CD8 tumor infiltrating lymphocytes, or TILs,
and I'll show that A20 sits at the heart of this problem.
I have no disclosures.
My talk today covers three major themes.
First, I'll show you how targeting A20 improves
adaptive cellular therapies, or ACTs.
Second, I'll discuss why A20 is an intriguing target with respect to
perforin.
And third, I'll highlight how targeting A20 unlocks a novel RIP3 CASP1
pathway in TILs.
Our story begins with a genome-wide CRISPR knockout screen to identify
suppressors of exhausted T cell persistence, for which we designed a
human T cell in vitro repetitive stimulation assay, or
RepSTim,
to mimic exhaustion.
One of the top enriched guide RNAs targeted
TNFAIP3, or A20,
suggesting that A20 is a critical enforcer of exhaustion.
We therefore tested the therapeutic potential of targeting A20 in
ACTs using human tumor models in immunodeficient mice.
In A375 melanoma
treated with Cas9-edited NY-ESO-1 specific TCR T
cells, A20 knockout in orange
dramatically improved tumor suppression compared to controls in blue
and improved survival across T cell donors.
We observed similar results in the Nalm6 B cell leukemia
model treated with CD19 CAR T cells.
Thus, targeting A20 enhances ACT potency in
solid and liquid
tumors.We next aim to
understand A20 biology in exhausted T cells.
A20 is a multifunctional enzyme that can add, remove, or
bind to ubiquitin on target proteins to regulate their activity.
It's best known as a suppressor of NF-kappa B, and
several studies have suggested that A20 restrains TIL
activity, though the underlying mechanisms were not defined.
We first aimed to dissect which domain within
the multifunctional A20 protein
was responsible for tumor immunity.
After using a protein large language model and a base editor tiling screen, we
narrowed the likely candidates to the OTU deubiquitinase,
the zinc finger four ubiquitin ligase, and the zinc finger
seven ubiquitin binding domains.
We then leveraged our panel of germline knock-in mice with A20
domain-specific inactivating mutations.
When we challenged with MC38 syngeneic tumors,
mice homozygous for the OTU or zinc finger four
mutations,
in red,
were no different than their wild type counterparts, in blue,
in terms of tumor growth and survival.
However, mice homozygous for the zinc finger seven mutation showed
dramatically improved tumor control and survival,
and nearly half cleared their tumors.
And we have data not shown that confirms the importance of CD8 intrinsic zinc
finger seven.
To apply this knowledge to ACTs, we used base editing
instead of Cas9 to generate a missense mutation that
precisely inactivates zinc finger seven.
For comparison, we also used base editing to generate A20 knockout via
premature stop codon.
Targeting zinc finger seven, in red, or A20
knockout, in orange,
with base editing greatly enhanced ACT activity against
A375 melanoma and Nalm6 leukemia.
Thus, zinc finger seven is a powerful and precise target for
enhancement of ACTs.
So why does zinc finger seven targeting improve TIL
performance?
We have data I won't show to suggest that it's not due to CD8 TIL
quantity, but that zinc finger seven instead impacts the phenotype
of terminally exhausted TILS or Ttex.
So from here on, I'll focus on Ttex.
To date, the field has mainly used cytokine expression as the
readout for Ttex dysfunction.
Accordingly, in zinc figure 7 mice, we saw a clear
increase
in Ttex expressing both interferon gamma and TNF.
We also found increased cytokine secretion by A20 targeted
ACTs.
However,
these cytokines were not required for MC38
control as genetic ablation of interferon gamma
and/or TNF
did not alter tumor immunity in zinc finger 7 mice.
This told us that another, more potent effector mechanism must be at play.
Far less is known about the perforin granzyme axis as a readout of Ttex
dysfunction, or whether it is regulated differently than cytokine
production.
In our MC38 model, perforin knockout completely reversed the
zinc finger seven tumor phenotype, suggesting a central role
for A20 in regulating perforin.
However, looking at perforin content by flow
cytometry, we observed a paradox.
Zinc finger seven Ttex had lower perforin expression than
wild type Ttex,
yet somehow perforin was required for tumor immunity in zinc finger seven
mice.
To make sense of this, we hypothesized that these lower
perforin levels indicated more degranulation.
In support of this,
ex vivo stimulated zinc finger 7 Ttex
secreted more perforin
and expressed more surface CD107a
with perforin production capacity that was otherwise similar to wild type
Ttex. Overall, suggesting increased degranulation.
To assess degranulation in situ, we used an in vivo
brefeldin treatment to block degranulation for six hours prior to
sacrifice.
This strategy revealed a striking differential in perforin
content within brefeldin-treated zinc finger seven, but
not wild type Ttex, suggesting zinc finger seven
Ttex are robustly degranulating in vivo and
wild type Ttex are not.
Finally,
A20 targeted ACTs secreted more perforin,
similar to our cytokine findings.
However, bulk RNA seq analysis revealed within these A20
targeted ACTs a transcriptional
upregulation of cytokines but not perforin.
Taken together, these results indicate that A20 differentially regulates
cytokine versus perforin release, the latter at the step of
degranulation rather than transcription.
Finally, we aim to dissect the post-transcriptional pathways connecting
A20 deficiency to degranulation, which ultimately led us to
RIP3.
RIP3 canonically
triggers necroptosis and cell death via MLKL,
and this is suppressed by A20.
Non-canonical RIP3 signaling is less well defined but
can involve the inflammasome and caspase-1.
This biology has primarily been described in myeloid cells.
Little is known about whether it operates in T
cellsNevertheless, in published
single cell transcriptomic data sets, we found MC38
Ttex and human Ttex
upregulated genes in this non-canonical pathway.
And remarkably, RIP3 ablation nearly
eliminated the tumor phenotype in zinc finger seven mice
and reversed the Ttex degranulation phenotype.
In addition, caspase-1 deficiency phenocopied RIP3
deficiency, but MLKL deficiency did not,
indicating non-canonical RIP3 was promoting perforin release and tumor
immunity.
To confirm that RIP3 and caspase-1's roles were CD8 intrinsic, we
developed a polyclonal CD8 T cell transfer model into
CD8 knockout mice.
Mice receiving zinc finger seven CD8 T cells showed
superior MC38 control compared to mice receiving wild type cells,
and this advantage was lost when the transferred cells were
either RIP3 or caspase-1 deficient, thus confirming the
CD8 intrinsic biology.
Furthermore,
caspase-1 activity
was increased in zinc finger seven Ttex,
and this required RIP3.
Finally, targeting both A20 and RIP3 in
ACTs erased their advantage in perforin release, but had
no impact on cytokine release.
To summarize, targeting A20 or zinc finger seven via
Cas9 or base editing in ACTs greatly enhanced their efficacy.
Zinc finger seven differentially regulates cytokine versus perforin effector
mechanisms, one at the level of transcription, one at degranulation.
And targeting zinc finger seven unlocks a non-canonical RIP3 caspase-1
axis that regulates perforin but not cytokine release.
We aim to further map the upstream and downstream signals in this axis, and we'll
try to exploit this pathway to enhance ACTs.
And finally, I want to acknowledge this amazing collaborative effort with
substantial contributions across three labs at UCSF.
Thank you for your attention.
Hi. Zaya Gill from Penn. That was really nice work.
So the increased degranulation,
better killing, but also within those effector cells or the
Ttex, at least, you're seeing evidence of activation of
non-canonical RIPK3 signaling. And so
I know you finished up by saying that's future work, but what do you speculate
is going-- Why is that not a deleterious thing to happen in the T cells?
Yeah.
We don't see an obvious cell death signal with the usual apoptosis
stains or the cell impermeable dyes.
So
we don't fully know
why it's
outside the world of cell death, per se, because obviously that would be a bad
thing for the T cells, you would think.
So we think it's
connected to possibly stress activation
pathways that, in the absence of A20, turn out to be
beneficial for this particular response.
But
it's possible that we're just unlocking
some curious new biology in the absence of A20
that somehow connects to this really highly
regulated step of degranulation.
But yeah, we
don't fully know. We know that it's not related to
IL1. We've done those knockout
experiments. We're still working on gasdermin D, but
again, that's a cell death related thing too.
So
it might end up requiring more high level proteomics to figure out.
But yeah, we don't fully know right now.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Great talk. This is Rob Manguso from MGH.
You mentioned that as part of your future directions, that you're looking at
upstream signaling, but because this can function
downstream of TNF, have you looked at
upstream signals like tumor necrosis factor or FAS as
potential-- Is there some rewiring of that signaling that's going on here
to turn what would have been possibly death signals
into something else?
Yeah. We haven't looked at FAS. The TNF we had, we had the full
knockout mice, and we don't think TNF is a big player in our system.
But yeah, we still need to look at FAS, for sure.
And of course, we're interested in
RIP1, CBP1. I think whatever we tie upstream, it
would be really fascinating.
But there's
kind of a lot of signals to explore.
Have you transcriptionally profiled the cells after A20 knockout?
Yeah. We have.
We have just done it in the human rep stem.
And
the biggest signal we get is a major metabolic
shift towards that
disfavors OXPHOS, and so we're trying to make sense of that because
that's also a phenomenon we see in A20 deficient macrophages,
which turns out to be beneficial in that they stay M1 instead
of they can't go to M2. We're trying to figure out why
that's beneficial for exhausted T cells as well.
So no obvious upregulation of NF-kappa B targets then?
Yeah. There's a lot of NF-kappa B
upregulation as well. But in terms of GSEA, aside from
the hallmark NF-kappa B,
the main thing that we didn't expect was the disfavoring of
OXPHOS.
I see. Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you.
But yeah, we get all the traditional, the expected
NF-?B upregulation as well.
Cool. Great talk.
All right. Thank you very much. Great talk.
All right. Next up is Marco Scheidegger, a graduate
student who comes to us from Buenos Aires.
He's going to talk to us about galectin-1 and exhausted CD8 T cells.
Hi. Thank you for the introduction.
Yeah, as you said, this is part of my ongoing PhD project.
I am currently in Buenos Aires in Argentina.
Mostly in our group, we focus on galectin-1, which I'm going to introduce in a bit.
And my project in particular focuses on how galectin-1
can
regulate this CD8 T cell dysfunction and exhaustion.
So these are my disclosure information.
And I thought I could start this talk not actually revisiting the whole cancer
immunity cycle. I'm sure you've heard it enough in this congress
so far, but rather by talking about what happens when T cells actually
reach the tumor site. And basically what happens is that they will
encounter a rather complex tumor microenvironment where there's
a balance or an imbalance, actually,
consisting of activating signals which would favor the anti-tumor response,
but mostly they will find a lot of immunosuppressive signals.
So there's a lot of activation of their co-inhibitory receptors, there's a lot of
different immunosuppressive myeloid populations.
And this imbalance in the tumor will eventually lead
up to what we call the CD8 dysfunction or exhaustion.
It's important to note that when we're talking about exhaustion, we're not talking
about just one specific phenotypic state in
CD8 T cells, but we're talking about a whole differentiation pathway.
So basically what happens is that because of repeated or
of chronic antigen stimulation, cells will progress in this
path going through what we call the progenitor exhausted T cells, winding up
in the terminally exhausted T cells.
And along this path, they will lose effector functions.
They will gain what we call a dysfunctional phenotype
coupled with increased co-inhibitory receptor expression,
loss of polyfunctional cytokines, and a lot of different
epigenetic and transcriptomic changes.
And while we do know a lot about how this program is carried out,
mainly chronic antigen stimulation being the driver, there are a
lot of different
soluble molecules in the microenvironment which could not drive this process, but
regulate this process, how far or how easy or how fast
can this process go. And one of these molecules is what we are focusing
on in our lab, which is galectin-1.
Galectin-1 is a glycan binding protein which in our lab we have studied
for the past 20 years. It has both intracellular and
extracellular functions, and it is highly expressed by
most tumors.
Along all the functions that we know of, mostly related to the immune
compartments, we know, for example, that galectin-1 promotes the
polarization of dendritic cells towards immunosuppressive
phenotype. We know it polarizes macrophages towards an M2-like
phenotype.
Regarding angiogenesis, we know that galectin-1 also favors
angiogenesis even during anti-VEGF blockade.
We know it favors the selective deletion of T helper 1 and
T helper 17 cells. We also know that it
expands Treg cells in tumor microenvironment.
And most recently, we found that it triggers immunosuppressive and
proangiogenic programs through what we call the myeloid-derived suppressor cells.
However, in all these years, we have always focused on galectin-1
derived from the tumor. So we know that most tumors produce galectin-1, and
we all
went rather deep with the functions of this tumor-derived galectin-1.
But for this work, we wanted to switch up the focus a bit and focus on what we call
the
host-derived galectin-1. We know host cells also produce
galectin-1. They can secrete it as well, and also immune cells can secrete
galectin-1. So in this case, we wanted to focus on immune cell-derived
Gal-1, and particularly what happens on T cells, which are the main
effectors of the anti-tumor response.
As a first approach, what we did was we analyzed publicly available single cell
RNA-seq data, and we found that as cells progress towards more exhausted
phenotypes, they will start secreting or expressing
actually more and more galectin-1.
And this coupled with our own in vivo studies, what we did was we first analyzed
a vaccination model. We vaccinated wild type and knockout mice with
B16-OVA tumors. And
while we did not see an improved control when we deleted, when
the mice lacked galectin-1 actually, when we analyzed at endpoint
the infiltrate of these tumors and we analyzed the T cell population, we
see that they are expressing less of this
exhaustion associated transcription factor, which is Tox.
So this led us to ask ourselves if
galectin-1 and exhaustion are not just a correlation, but maybe a
causation. So our main question in this work was does
endogenous galectin-1 or T cell-derived galectin-1 shape this
T cell exhaustion and dysfunction?
As a first approach, what we did, what we turned to in vitro models of exhaustion,
we simulate what happens on the cancer immunity cycle, basically by
repeating antigen stimulation on T cells.
So we activate them, we let them rest for a few days, and then we reactivate them.
And the first thing we did was we validated our
results or the public results from the single cell RNA-seq,
and we verified that upon chronic stimulation of T cells
they are expressing more and more galectin-1.
And then comparing wild type or knockout cells
first we validated the model.
We analyzed by flow cytometry expression of PD-1, and we see that after
the second reactivation, they express higher levels of PD-1, which will
validate that these cells are actually going through this exhaustion pathway.And
then when we analyzed TIM-3 expression, which is associated with terminal
exhaustion, we were surprised to see that knockout cells actually express more
TIM-3, so they would seem to be more exhausted.
However, it's important to know that when we're talking about exhaustion, there's
not just one single marker that defines whether a cell is
terminally or progenitorly exhausted.
So we turned to see what happens with the
master regulators of transcription.
And we went to see two of the main transcription factors associated with this
process. So TCF7 is associated with
stem-like phenotype, and TOX is a master regulator of
telomere differentiation in CD8 T cells.
And the first thing we see when we analyze the wild type cells is
that upon this reactivation, they are losing expression of
TCF7, so they are losing this stem-like phenotype, and they are gaining
expression of the terminally exhausted transcription
factor, which is TOX. However, when we look at the knockout cells
lacking galectin-1, we do see the same loss of TCF7, but we do
not see any gain of TOX expression.
So they would seem to be less exhausted in this case.
And more importantly, when we analyze the functional phenotype of these cells, we
see that they are more functional, characterized by higher expression of interferon
gamma and TNF alpha.
After this, we wanted to go to mouse in vivo models,
and we chose an antigen-specific model, which is the OT-1 cells.
They are specific for OVA peptides.
And we took these cells and using CRISPR-Cas9, we knocked down
galectin-1. Here's the validation of that knockout.
And we took these cells, and we transferred them into B and T cell deficient
Rag2 knockout mice which were carrying B16 OVA tumors, so
this is melanoma. And we see a trend towards improved control
when the CD8 T cells that we're transferring are knocked out for
galectin-1. And again, when we analyze this infiltrate at endpoint,
we see a more functional phenotype.
So they're expressing more interferon gamma, and they have higher cytotoxic
capacity measured by granzyme B expression.
So this far,
at least, we are convinced that there is some relation with
galectin-1, and it's driving somehow the dysfunction and exhausted
phenotypes in these cells. So we wondered what possible mechanism
could this be happening through. We switched to
other members of the galectin family, and we found, for example, this is
widely known, that galectin-9, for example, can bind to PD-1 and TIM-3.
It can activate these receptors and lead to persistent of exhausted
T cells. We also know that galectin-3 can bind to PD-1 and to LAG-3
and also lead to T cell dysfunction.
They have also several roles in the myeloid compartment.
So we wondered if galectin-1 could be acting in a similar fashion.
So our next question was, does galectin-1 bind to these co-inhibitory
receptors, and then can it activate them?
So as a first approach, what we did was we took a set of co-inhibitory
molecules, mainly PD-1, CTLA4, TIM-3, LAG-3,
TIGIT, and VISTA, and we did a set of studies to see if there was any
binding. And the first thing we did was a lectin blot, where we see that galectin-1
actually binds to these receptors with different affinities to most of
the receptors actually. We didn't see any binding to the TIM-3 in this
case.
Then we verified this with a different assay, the solid phase assay.
We again saw galectin-1 binding to the receptors with different affinities.
And in this case, we also saw that when we put lactose in the mix, we
abrogated all binding, and this proved that it's a glycan-dependent interaction.
Then we took two of these receptors, LAG-3 and VISTA, because it's the
ones we saw the highest binding with.
We verified with isothermal titration calorimetry.
And again, we quantified binding of Gal-1 to LAG-3 with a KD of around
12 or 13 micromolar, and to VISTA with a KD of
almost 3 micromolar.
Finally, we did some biolayer interferometry assays with VISTA in
particular, and we again saw a quite strong binding of galectin-1 to
this receptor and verified once more that this binding is actually
glycan-dependent. So this is all the work I wanted to show you today.
So just as a wrap-up, we can see that galectin-1
expression increases during T cell exhaustion and that this
promotes dysfunction. So
the next thing we're
planning to develop this work is analyzing what intracellular
functions of galectin-1 could possibly be involved in this process.
Next, we saw that endogenous galectin-1 limits the antitumor
capacity of these cells, and we're wondering if that could possibly be
a target for new therapies.
Mainly, can we block Gal-1 in T cells and improve
adopted cell transfer regimens? And
finally, we know that galectin-1 binds to a set of these co-inhibitory
molecules, and we're not just staying there.
We want to know if this is not only binding but also activation.
So the first thing we're going to do is analyze functionally if galectin-1 can
actually activate signaling pathways through these receptors, and if so, if
this could be a possible mechanism of resistance to immune checkpoint
blockade therapies. So we hope to be moving forward in this matter.
And with that, I wanted to thank all my group for their everyday work,
and thank you all for listening.
Thanks very much. We have some time for questions.
I can start with one. I'm interested in sort of the extracellular
role and the level of galectin-1 on T cells versus other cells in the tumor
microenvironment. Do you have an idea of sort of comparative levels
and therefore maybe comparative contribution in binding
those inhibitory receptors on T cells?
We haven't actually compared all the immune population,
how much galectin-1 they produce.
But we know that in some tumors, the tumor can actually
induce fibroblasts to express a lot of galectin-1.
And-That's very interesting, at least because we know that the tumor
microenvironment will have a lot of galectin-1.
But in this case, we wanted to focus on the T cell
galectin-1, mainly because of
an intrinsic mechanism of exhaustion.
But it's very interesting to analyze what would happen across the different
populations as well.
Great talk. This is Robin Gusso from the MGH.
I noticed in your
mechanism section there, you were talking about galectin-1 binding checkpoints
like LAG-3 and VISTA and possibly DIGIT.
I missed, how did you arrive at those inhibitory receptors?
Which is basically we analyzed what receptors are
actually the ones that are targeted right now for therapy.
So like PD-1, CTLA-4, and I think lately LAG-3 are
actually being targeted. And basically, what other receptors are in
the way for being approved as possible targets.
Yeah.
So that's basically our line of thought.
Well, because one thing I think about is galectin-1 binds Glycnac, right?
Mm-hmm.
So there are
a number of ligands on T cells that are heavily glycosylated proteins
like CD2, CD7, and CD43.
And some of those, especially CD2, are important for T cell activation.
Yeah.
And have you guys considered that these are known galectin-1
ligands, and possibly interfering with their function or
cross-linking them in some way
could possibly inhibit T cell responses?
Do you know if it's dependent on cell intrinsic glycosylation?
You show lactose as a way to sort of block it, but you
could also strip the T cells of their-
Yeah
...
glycans.
Yeah, of course.
Basically, we focus on
co-inhibitory receptors because we know they have signaling pathways that will lead
to T cell exhaustion. But other members in our group are
also,
I wouldn't say they're focusing, but they study how galectin-1 binds to other
molecules in myeloid cells or T cells as well.
And it's not something we're not aware of.
I'm not focusing on that. And about your other comment,
yeah, it's very interesting because we know
it binds to different glycans, and in fact, these glycans are modified on the
tumor site. They're modified not only on tumor site, but on
the activation pathway. For example, as T cells are
activated versus the naive cell, they will start expressing more
galectin-1 permissive glycans, so the galectin-1 could bind more.
And of course, on tumor site, glycophenotype of the cells will be
different than that of in vitro cells, for example.
It's definitely something we are keeping in mind, and we actually have some
experiments. I can't tell you any results yet, but to
analyze that.
That's great. Thank you. Nice talk.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you very much.
Okay. Last talk of this session is Yaita Senat from
the Broad Institute of MIT and Harvard, and she's going to tell us about
her work understanding compensatory signaling
after PTPN 1 and 2 blockade.
Thank you, Megan, for the introduction, and the organizers for the opportunity to
present my work here. We've been hearing amazing talks about how we can
rewire T cell signaling and functionality.
And over the next 10 minutes, I'll share how we have addressed this question.
And to do this, we focus on a target that our lab has been deeply investigating for
some years now, which is the phosphatase PTPN2.
I have nothing to disclose.
PTPN2 is a protein tyrosine phosphatase that regulate a variety of cellular
processes by either dephosphorylating receptors or non-receptor protein
tyrosine kinases, which could include JAK and STAT proteins.
In T cells, PTPN2 is a critical checkpoint for cytokine and TCR signaling,
and inhibition or deletion of PTPN2 enhances T cell function,
increasing proliferation, effector function, and activation.
Some years ago, our lab described how either systemic inhibition of
PTPN2 with the cytactive inhibitor AC44 or PTPN2
knockout CAR T cells were able to effectively control tumors, in some
cases even better than anti-PD-1 treatment.
And this antitumor response was mediated by a unique population
of CD8 T cells that show enhanced memory and effector
phenotype and a reduced exhaustion.
And our analysis of these cells also show striking JAK-STAT
signaling pathways upregulated in these cells, including IL6,
JAK-STAT, or IL2, STAT5.
However, this data also highlights two main limitations.
The first one, that PTPN2 is not sufficient to induce curative responses.
And secondly, that the exact signaling mechanisms
happening in these enhanced effector T cells inhibited for
PTPN2 remains unclear. And so by mapping the signaling
pathways happening in these cells, we will be able to optimize
strategies to improve T cell function.
And so to address this question and to study the impact of
PTPN2 on exhaustion, we develop a chronic stimulation assay based on the
repetitive stimulation of T cells with anti-CD3/CD28 beads in
the presence of low concentration of IL-2.
We then characterize this cell by single cell.
And to characterize individual cytokine signaling pathways occurring in these cells
by single cell, we make use of the CytoSig analysis.
CytoSig is a curated database of known cytokine responses
and a predictive model developed by the Oguchida Finney lab.
And so by cross-referencing our transcriptomic data to these
established gene signatures, the model is capable of
predicting which cytokine networks are happening in our samples.
And we then cross-validate our findings by phosphoproteomics and flow
cytometry.
And so we perform this chronic stimulation assay either in the presence or absence
of this PTPN2 inhibitor, and then we collect the cells at the end of the assay and
perform single-cell RNA seq. And consistent with our previous
in vivo models-Pre-chronically stimulated T cells inhibited for
PTPN2 show enhanced memory gene signatures and also
depletion of terminal exhausted genes.
And this was also further validated by flow cytometry.
When we look at AC484 T cells, these cells express lower
PD-1, lower TIM-3, also lower TOX and CD39.
And so we next attempt to identify which were the key signaling events
happening in these cells. And as I mentioned, we used the CyTOsig analysis.
And I'm showing here chronic CD8s, but we observed the same results in CD4s.
And we observed that in these chronically stimulated T cells, there was a strong
upregulation of IL-10, STAT3 pathways, also IL-21,
STAT3, and STAT1 pathways. But at the same time, we observe a
downregulation of the IL-2/STAT5 pathway.
And this was most consistent with downregulation of canonical STAT5 effector
molecules and upregulation of STAT3 transcription factors.
And to further confirm that these findings were not
specific for the in vitro assay, we then performed the same analysis
on our previous published single-cell RNA-seq data of tumors treated
with AC484 drug. And when we look at these T cells from these tumors,
again, we observe that there was an upregulation of IL-10, STAT3, also
IL-6, STAT3 pathways, also interferon and STAT1 pathways.
But again, a downregulation of the IL-2/STAT pathway.
And we then cross-validate these findings by phosphoproteomics and
also by flow cytometry. So we perform again the chronic stimulation assay.
We collect the cells at the end of the assay and perform phosphoproteomics and also
characterize the assays by flow cytometry.
And we were able to
recover more than 50,000 phosphopeptides in our phosphoproteomic analysis, so this
was a very rich data set.
And similarly to the CyTOsig analysis, we observed a
decreased number of phosphopeptides for JAK proteins, especially JAK1,
and also for phosphopeptides of STAT5A and STAT5B.
And similarly to the single-cell RNA-seq, we do observe increased
number of phosphopeptides for STAT3 and STAT1.
And we then validate this by flow cytometry using specific phospho-site
antibodies for p-STAT3, STAT1, and STAT5.
As you can see here, STAT3 is one of the main pathways upregulated in these
cells, and we observe increased number of p-STAT3
levels in our PTPN2-inhibited T cells compared to the DMSO
group. And the magnitude of this increase is even greater as the cells become
more exhausted if we compare day
14 with day six.
And this was also true for p-STAT1.
But if we look at p-STAT5, even though PTPN2-inhibited T cells
show higher levels of p-STAT5 compared to the DMSO group, the
magnitude of this increase is significantly smaller if we
compare it to on day six when the cells are not yet fully
exhausted. And this is summarized here, where it highlights
that STAT3 and STAT1 pathways are the main pathways activated in these
chronically stimulated T cells. And so these were very
surprising finding for us since us and others have shown that
acutely stimulated T cells inhibited for PTPN2 show a
strong IL-2/STAT5 pathway as well.
This is indeed what we observe in acutely stimulated cells.
And so to nominate potential
mechanisms responsible for this downregulation of STAT5, we went back
to the single cell, and we look at genes induced by the STAT3 pathway
since this was one of the main pathways upregulated in these cells.
And so when we look at genes induced by STAT3 pathways that were
upregulated in our PTPN2-inhibited T cells, one of them was SOCS3.
And this was not only true in the in vitro exhaustion assay, but if we look again
on the TILs from tumors treated with the AC484 drug,
these cells also overexpress SOCS3.
And SOCS3 is a known inhibitor of JAK-STAT pathway.
It's usually induced by IL-10, IL-6, or IL-21/STAT3 pathways.
And when it's expressed, SOCS3 can bind directly the active site of
JAK proteins, and it
therefore stops further STAT5 phosphorylation, but it also marks
these JAK proteins for degradation.
And so we hypothesized that SOCS3 could be one of
the
potential candidates mediating this
downregulation of the IL-2/STAT5 pathway.
And to test this hypothesis, we generate knockout T cells for
PTPN2, SOCS3, or double knockout T cells for PTPN2 and
SOCS3. We then perform the chronic stimulation assay, and then we characterize the
cells at the end of this assay. The first thing that we notice is that
double knockout PTPN2 and SOCS3 show strong
levels of IL-2/STAT5 compared to the
single knockouts.
There was also a slight increase in p-STAT3, but this
pathway is already really active in these cells, so not much increase here.
But then there was also a strong upregulation of this
p-STAT1 protein compared to the single knockouts.
And if we look at the exhaustion state of these cells, we found that these
double knockout cells express lower levels of PD-1,
also lower expression of LAG-3 and
TOX. And so the last thing that we wanted to
look at is whether these cells can actually kill better in vitro
cancer cells. And so we perform again this chronic stimulation assay.
At the end of the assay, we co-cultured the T cells with this modified
K562 cell line, which expresses the CD3/CD80 construct, and this
allows the activation of the T cell in an antigen-independent fashion.
And if we perform this co-culture experiment, and I'm here showing different
effector-target ratios,
the double knockout PTPN2/SOCS3 were capable of killing a higher number of
cancer cells 48 hours after this co-culture.
And we believe one of the
reasons of this result
is related to the proportion of CD8s and CD4 in the culture.
We know that during this chronic stimulation assay, there's a huge drop in the
number of CD8s.So by day 15, we know
that the number of CD8s ranges between 10% and 20%, and there's
a huge population of CD4s.
But if we look at the double knockouts, the double knockouts were capable of
preserving the CD8 during this stressful condition much better.
And not only this, but if we look at interferon gamma and perforin production,
these double knockout cells also produce more interferon gamma and perforin
and similar levels of granzyme B.
And so overall,
PTPN2 knockout unleash several JAK-STAT
pathways, including STAT5, STAT1, and STAT3, and this is
beneficial for the T cell in increased activation and proliferation.
However, during chronic stimulation, there is a predominance of
the STAT3 program, which is also advantageous for the cell because it
is the main program for survival of T cells in chronic
condition and stressful conditions.
But it also induces some counterregulatory pathways such as SOX3.
When SOX3 is expressed in these cells, this can be limiting the
JAK-STAT pathways in these cells.
And so by knocking SOX3, we are capable of generating more
exhaustion-resistant T cells that have enhanced STAT5 and STAT1
signaling pathways, which is translated also in more production of interferon gamma
and also better persistence of CD8s.
And so future studies will map the signaling dynamics of these double knockout
cells, and we also plan to do some in vivo models to evaluate the capacity
of these cells to kill tumors. And with this, I would like to thank all my
lab, especially Rob, Kathleen, and Kevin,
for their guidance on this project.
Also, the Broad Bio omics for their help in the
phosphoproteomics experiments, and the Sen Lab for their contribution as well.
And thank you to all of you, and happy to take questions.
Questions?
Oops. Not for short people. Great talk.
So in the Nature paper, Baumgartner
2023, it is shown that
Rafi Ahmed's signature of
chronically stimulated CD8 T cells,
IL-2/STAT5 signature,
really is similar to CD8 T cells
that are treated with AC4A4.
And that signature was in chronic stimulation of
LCMV model. There, they treated with IL-2 and
PD-1 combinatorial therapy.
However, here you're showing that
STAT5/IL-2 signature is down. So
I was just wondering about that, if you can clarify.
And my next question is, if you have less SOX,
then you will have less interferon gamma
when you treat CD8 T cells with AC4A4 in
chronically stimulated CD8 T cells.
So is it something that you're observing, less interferon gamma in these cells?
So, to the first part of your question,
I do believe that how all these pathways are
increased or down-regulating the T cells, it's also very
context dependent. In our
cases, we have pan T cell cultures, so we have CD8s and CD4s.
I do believe that the CD4s in our cultures are
driving some of this also down-regulation of a STAT5 pathway because they
are producing more IL-10, IL-21 pathways, which are going to increase STAT3
signaling, and then it's going to counteract STAT5.
We've done this experiment in CD8s only, when you only have
CD8s in the culture. And this down-regulation of a
STAT5 pathway is actually not
as
striking. I will say even it doesn't reach significance.
So there is no down-regulation
when you only have CD8s. And we're performing cultures
in which we have CD4s because we believe that's actually what you're going to find
in vivo and also in humans. And so I
think that could be the explanation why
in some of the experiments from this paper, they were using
only CD8. It was also in mouse, so we are doing human, but still, I think those
were only CD8 culture experiments.
And that goes in line with our only CD8 experiment as
well, where IL-2/STAT5 pathways also are regulated.
And you do see less interferon gamma?
We do see more interferon gamma, and I think I showed in the last slide
in the double knockouts compared to the single knockouts.
All right. Thank you. Great talk.
Nick Haining. Thank you. That was a really beautiful talk.
So in a double knockouts, when you're knocking out SOX3 in the PTPN2
deficient cells, SOX3 could be doing a number of things.
Mm.
It makes sense that it's
rescuing the phospho-STAT5 defect, but it could be something else.
So can you achieve the same rescue just by adding a
boatload of IL-2?
You mean by adding IL-2 to the CD8 culture without knocking out SOX3?
Yeah. In just PTPN2 deficient cells, can you
achieve the same rescue of the deficient phospho-STAT5
state?
So these experiments are performed during
this experiment in low concentration of IL-2.
We haven't
specifically re-stimulated the cells with IL-2 and see if we can
recover the IL-2/STAT5 signaling.
Got it. And then the second question, you started off by saying that
PTPN2 knockout changes the sort of
disposition of the cells for developing T cell exhaustion.
Do you infer that that's a STAT3 dependent process?
Is STAT3 shifting the differentiation states of the cell?
So we still have a strong STAT3 signaling in our double
knockout with SOCS3, and we still see some
down-regulation of
exhaustion markers as well.
Definitely, yes, STAT5 is one of the main programs for effector T
cells states, and
we observed less exhaustion in PTPN2 knockout T cells, but we
still observe this less exhaustion phenotype in the double
knockout.
So yeah.
Thank you.
And there was a talk earlier by Phil Greenberg
basically showing that during exhaustion, the CD8s kind of fall to the
wayside, and CD4s seem to take over in the cytotoxic actual cell
killing. With these double knockouts, are you seeing a
TH1 skew in your CD4? Or especially at the end, you showed that you are
actually maintaining a CD8. Is it just the CD8s are continually
able to divide and grow, or have you checked that?
This is a great question. We actually performed all this experiment
last week, so I haven't had enough time
to specifically study how this is
happening. I did some TH1,
T17 phenotype, but I couldn't do it in the chronic stimulation assays of
these were only T cells knockout and then expanded in
IL-2.
It did seem that in the double knockouts, there was
a slight increase in the percentage of
TH1 like 17 phenotype.
But we haven't studied further that. That's a great point.
Do you see similar phenotype? I think your in vitro re-stimulation assay
utilized anti-CD3 and anti-CD28 antibodies, which is a
pretty potent T cell activator. So I'm curious if you see
this in other contexts, maybe when you repetitively stimulate with tumor cells
or
in T cells from mice treated with AC44 ex
vivo.
Do you mean the
STAT5, STAT3 signaling pathways?
Yes.
That's a great point. It's true that this RepSTIM assay with the Dynabeads is
pretty strong, and we are planning to do experiments also with cancer cells at
our next step as well.
At least when we perform the cytosite analysis
on TLs from tumor treated with AC44 in vivo,
these cells also show strong IL10, IL6, STAT3
pathways and then regulation of the IL2, STAT5 pathway.
Thank you.
Okay.
All right.
So
thank you, everybody. I think just for the sake of time and because we want
to get out into this beautiful San Diego afternoon, I'll
be brief, and I'll just say thanks to the presenters today for sharing really some
outstanding work, sort of next generation T cell
targets. I think moving the field forward at this point is going to
be
challenging. There are so many targets now that people are uncovering.
How do I identify the best targets to move forward with in
clinical trials? So again, everybody have a good afternoon, and thanks for coming.